despite months and months of pressure
and mandates and emotional manipulation
a lot of americans still don't want to
take
the experimental drug to stop the cough
that for a lot of people most people
even doesn't pose a particularly grave
threat oh you can't say that anymore and
the libs are furious about it they're
furious the libs are are melting down
they're posting their meltdowns to
tick-tock i don't want to sound like a
sexist here there seems to be a little
bit of a skew
in favor of women when it comes to these
meltdowns i just have a lot of feelings
i don't make the reality i'm just
observing it and so i decided as i often
try to do i don't want to just make fun
of the libs i don't want to own them
just to own them for owning sake i want
to own them with a purpose okay i want
to take their arguments as seriously as
i can figure out what it is they're
trying to say so my producers have put
together
the top
lib
anti-vaxx or i guess provacs against the
anti-vaxx tiktok videos of hysterical
women
and i'm going to choose the most
persuasive argument
let us begin
my daughter just called and her
boyfriend has tested positive
he's the only person in his work that's
wearing a mask
out of you know 300 people
and now my daughter who's 29 weeks
pregnant is at risk
and uh
i hate
every single
one of you
who refuses to wear a mask to protect
others i
hope this virus finds you i hope it
finds you and i hope it
destroys you because the people that are
trying to do their part in this are
getting sick because of you stupid
ignorance
morons
so
please get vaccinated
so
her anger
is coming from this a place of concern
for her daughter because your daughter's
pregnant and her daughter's husband has
the virus and so she's really afraid for
her daughter and then she gets really
upset and yells and screams and
everything calm down just calm down my
wife was pregnant during most of the
coronavirus well i can't say most of
because it's going to go on forever but
my wife was pregnant from
what april of 2020 she was pregnant for
the whole thing
we almost never wore masks we had had
people over all the time we went to
people's houses we traveled all over the
place we obviously weren't daxed
and
the baby's it's super healthy it's great
it's totally cool it's not a big deal
the other problem with her argument is
she's saying you know because they're
not wearing masks that now the the thing
people are being infected so i guess the
mask doesn't prevent you from being
infected it only prevents you from
giving the infection to other people but
then so the guy's got the virus but then
the wife doesn't even have the virus yet
at the time of this video and not really
persuasive at all next one i'm not even
so much upset with the anti-vaxxers as
much
as i am with those that are responsible
for the brainwashing suggestive speech
the um
now gaslighting that they're doing now
as they're backpedaling saying oh no no
no
we always believed in vaccines oh masks
are good
who's doing that i'm not doing that back
battling uh-uh yeah you know what [ __ ]
right off
right off
because now your constituents are
filling up the hospitals and the icu's
and are dying
and
i actually i care
oh yeah they were anti-vaxxers but i
care oh that's nice okay
um
those that should have been showing
example that should have been leading
uh especially in our last administration
didn't
all of this could have been helped if
trump would have just put a [ __ ] mask
on and talked about how masks are
effective and once we got the vaccine
how the vaccine is effective along with
the rest of the right-wing media and
politicians and now you're going to come
out of your hole and completely change
your tune [ __ ] off
so
the masks are effective and if only
trump had said that the masks are
effective
we wouldn't be in this mess and the
masks are so effective
that we had to
still keep the entire
society locked down until we got a
vaccine because the masks are so
effective that we can't go back to
normal life until we get a vaccine
because the masks aren't effective but
then we got the vaccine and then anyone
who wanted the vaccine got the vaccine
and the vaccine is very effective you
see and the vaccine is so effective that
the people who got the vaccine already
need to put masks back on because the
people who got the vaccine are getting
the virus because they're very effective
and this is trump's fault because trump
wouldn't
get the vaccine well he did get the
vaccine he actually i guess he developed
the vaccine under operation warp speed
then he got the vaccine and actually it
was democrats who said they probably
wouldn't get the vaccine up to it
including joe biden and kamala harris if
donald trump tells us i should that we
should take it i'm not taking it but
she's this woman is very upset
that people are making their own health
care decisions in a way that is
basically only affecting them right
because all the hospitalizations as she
said are just the people without the
vaccine that's what we're being told
okay so it's not affecting the people
who did what she wants them to do and
get the vaccine so it's only affecting
themselves and she's very upset
because
the masks didn't work as well as they
told us they would and the vaxis didn't
work as well as they told us they would
you are skinning on very very thin ice
okay not following that
next one y'all i completely lost my mind
for a minute so i'm in a store i walk up
to the checkout line to pay of course
have my mask on the guy in front of me
big old bald-headed redneck looking dude
probably a white supremacist
and he turns around and is like there's
another sheep
and my automatic response like without
even thinking
was to stand there and
i go i realize that's the worst sheep
noise in the whole world but i made
sheep noises at him very loudly and
aggressively and i have never seen a
huge grown-ass man be so scared of a
five-foot-two woman in my entire life
like he got his sh and got out of there
so the next time some trump humper calls
you a snowflake or a sheep or whatever
just match their level of crazy the next
time someone calls you a sheep prove
them right congratulations you played
yourself
okay
all right first of all somebody tells me
he wasn't like scared he was probably
scared for her well-being as we all are
we're scared for all of these people's
well-being and it's not from the virus
either it's it's from the mind virus
it's from this the soul virus i actually
like this girl i mean she's admitting
she's saying yeah we're i'm a sheep i'm
a i will do anything fauci tells me to
do yeah govern me harder fauci yeah tell
me what to do absolutely
so
i i like her i mean i'm i find this uh
persuasive and i think this reflects
reality next one you know what
special needs kids
starts a conversation like that
the whole lot of you
parents families
your caregivers therapists your doctors
all you special needs out there right
right because that's what your mother
say to us
when you don't want to get vaccinated
because it's not fda approved yet you
have to
contour your face without looking at one
ingredient and you will go to
starbucks never once checking to see if
the fda has approved pumpkin spice right
well if it's a starbucks it has been
approved if you
knew what it took for me to get my kid
from the front door to the car seat you
would understand that i would wear a
mask every day for the rest of my life
but your body autonomy right right so
apparently if we're special needs we
just get to stay home because of you
selfish you know what i'm done chat
karen
a lot of you okay i actually couldn't
make sense of most of what she was
saying because because every other word
was an expletive which our producers
have to bleep out so i i didn't hear
most of her argument but she was saying
how who cares that the experimental drug
wasn't approved by the fda because
although now what i think now one of
them is or something it's in the process
but if a food product makes it to market
in america that means that it has gone
through
regulators so it actually you don't need
to check because you know that but the
fda actually came out with this
vaccine and said well this is this is an
emergency youth authorization
but not a full authorization you can't
simultaneously tell us that this is an
epidemic of the unvaccinated and the
only people going to hospitals and dying
or the unvaccinated you'll be shocked to
to hear this she doesn't know what she's
talking about
and it's it's pretty transparent i think
all right here's the last one here we go
my
empathy fatigue
is so real do not ask me to give a [ __ ]
about you when you get sick
and you haven't had the vaccine i don't
care
i don't care
i
don't
care
if you get sick
empathy fatigue is more like
empathy rage
so the woman obviously doesn't know what
the word empathy means because she's
saying she you know she doesn't like
these people and she hopes they get sick
and she doesn't care about them at all
so empathy is when when you have a
feeling for someone based on a perceived
sort of similarity well i could see
myself in their place i can i can know
how this feels right as opposed to
sympathy which is like well i don't
really know how that feels but i feel
bad for you anyway empathy is like i
know i see myself in that situation but
she doesn't she manifestly does not so
it's the opposite of empathy also if you
have empathy fatigue you don't have much
empathy in the first place also empathy
is not a great guide for for anything
libs love to talk about empathy now even
though they apparently don't know what
it means but
a much better guide to your interactions
with your neighbors than empathy or
sympathy is charity it's charity it's
caring for someone it is willing the
good of the other person going out of
your way whether or not you see yourself
in that person just going out and being
kind to them and caring for them and
performing loving acts for them and
giving arms but the libs don't have
charity and and actually if you talk to
very ideological left-wing politicians
or you read you know leftist theorists
they will they will tell you they
actually hate charity they hate charity
because they think that charity is an
impediment to revolution so whitaker
chambers talks about this in in witness
he says that they walked he and another
communist walked by a bomb on the street
they wanted to hand him a nickel but
they said no you can't that chair that
will deaden the revolutionary spirit or
bernie sanders said the same thing he
goes i don't like charity i don't i want
there to be a revolution and then we
won't need to give charity the american
people are tired of women they don't
like charity uh this woman's obviously
not charitable or empathetic or
particularly sympathetic
the winner is so obvious you know i
don't even need to say it it's the sheep
obviously the sheep bi is the only one
who made a convincing arg an argument
actually with which i cannot
argue let me know in the comments
section if you agree with my pick for
for the absolute top most persuasive
lib covid meltdown post other videos you
want me to review next we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]